let's go to our next caller from the
6-1-6 area code caller from six one six
who's this what's on your mind now my
name is Ken and I'm from Holland
Michigan area I'm just wondering who's
paying for Trump to go off to all these
political rallies it's not supposed to
be the taxpayer but I'm just wondering
how much money the tax pickers are
kicking in for it you are paying ken
yeah I mean yes so I think the idea is I
mean listen I believe the way it's
supposed to work is that if Trump
travels on Air Force One to what is
effectively a campaign rally the
campaign is supposed to reimburse the
government for the cost of that trip but
it's not officially a campaign event
even though Trump has filed reelection
papers so you're paying for it and I'm
paying for it we're all paying for it
okay that's what I figured but I thought
that the Republican National Committee
was supposed to pay for the rallies
themselves you're probably right
they had they had Michael Cohen as their
finance chair up until very recently so
if you think that then the RNC is going
to be the place where things are running
the way they should be they are not ken
thank you appreciate the call yeah
people should be more angry about that
if you're a small government
conservative you you really should be
against that